Kawai you held an explosive team to just
92 points what impact do you think the
defense you guys played on the staff had
on their group overall the tremendous
players you know outside player we're
just trying to come out and play hard
every every night we out here and women
our mistakes as much as possible
you know we end up with the win tonight
they send an awful lot of attention
defensively in your direction how do you
somehow maintain your patience and still
be productive collide
I don't play here a basketball my plan
for you know fans or you know you know
I'm just playing a win I'm not out here
trying to record whatever is on a
scoreboard I know my team win mark and
Jeff were talking to lie about Kyle
Lowry making every right decision in the
second half can you describe the effect
he has when he plays aggressively as he
has his last couple games he's our
quarterback he's right the basketball
player are you showing that right now
you know he wants to way back we are
playing away and we don't care who this
is who gets the shine whoever night it
is that's the night it is Serge was
tested early in this series but in the
last couple of games in several quarters
he has been dynamic what effect is he
having on the remote forest he's out
there's Park and many of them they are
going crazy and you are going back home
is terribly a championship coming
they're ready to play focus no turnovers
play defense and get some good shots
thank you very much Mike all right Doris
Leonard can hardly contain himself to
butter up believable performances this
stoic superstar is one of the most
unique players we've ever seen in the
game not just for his two-way ability
but his demeanor on the court at office
a magnificent performance from one of
those special players in the NBA